today I am taking matters into my own
hands
with the new 2020 MacBook Air I
personally really really like this new
laptop Apple did a great job they
doubled the base storage as far as the
SSDs they lower the price by $100 they
gave us a new keyboard
they put a new tenth generation Intel
processors they have really good single
core performance in fact it actually
beat out the rest of the MacBook lineup
everything is super snappy for regular
tasks but when you start hitting it with
a heavier load both for CPU and for
graphics it really starts to slow down
now that is because Apple still did not
put a heat pipe between their cooler and
their fan so today I will be water
cooling this MacBook Air and I'll be not
only testing on this solution which is
not permanent more like just for fun to
see what we get but also much easier
simpler solution to see what kind of
performance can we actually get or what
could we have gone if Apple did a better
job with this laptop so let's go ahead
and open up this box now I'll go ahead
and leave a link to the cooler that I'm
using down in the video description it
is inexpensive gets good ratings and
it's very slim over here compared to
other ones which is why I think it's
going to be easier to test it out with
this setup here let's go ahead and slide
this off perfect and let's go ahead and
connect the fan first and let me
carefully see if I can place this and I
really hope I don't break this right now
okay you got this place flat and we are
gonna need a way to power this cooler so
here's my son's PC that he built with me
do you guys need a fun video to go watch
if you guys are quarantine stuck at home
definitely go and check that out and now
let's take off the bottom cover on the
MacBook Air thankfully this is easier
than the pros but you do need a special
bit can leave a link for you guys to
this awesome I fixed a tool kit alright
and here we go you guys see that little
heatsink right there that is not
connected to the fan why not look
there's some room here this ribbon cable
could be lifted or moved let's see here
alright what kind of contact do we get
here
we do have some contact actually yeah
not too bad and now is the time for me
to tell you guys please don't do this at
home please don't risk your new MacBook
Air this is just for fun I'm gonna put a
some thermal solution on here a little
bit thermal paste probably shouldn't be
doing this but it's done no turning back
now and I put a little bit too much on
so I am using my Apple card to get some
of it off so what you get Apple for not
putting a proper cooling solution in
here okay and now for the moment of
truth okay why is my heart pounding so
so much is it cuz I've never done
anything I don't know either smart or as
dumb as this let's go ahead and turn on
this PC take that off here how do I do
this the right way I guess there is
really no right way to do this let's set
the MacBook Air on top there try to get
a decent contact as I said before this
is definitely not a permanent solution
and it's logging in is it really idling
at 24 degree Celsius we haven't really
done anything yet but that idle is good
no it is just kind of balancing on that
cooler okay well I think that's the best
that we're gonna get it I have to just
put a little bit of weight on the laptop
to make sure has good contact the first
question I guess is Geekbench v
multi-core score oh it worked I didn't
see a temperature above I don't know 70
75 degrees and single core is pretty
close but as far as the multi-core score
we just got an improvement of about 23
percent and it's slightly beating out
the MacBook Pro now but of course this
test wasn't the one where it was just
horribly sucking at Livanos where I'll
be sucking at it was cinema jar 20 which
we put it where that's where we put a
full 100 percent load on the CPU and
also gaming so let's take this a step
further
all right let's hit CPU right there and
we just had 3.5 gigahertz going down a
little bit
temps are
going up okay 97 degrees Celsius okay
well now it's going down now that was
almost 35 watts of power I don't think I
saw it go that high and we're running at
58 degrees Celsius
okay 62 typically literally as soon as
it hit a hundred right there it would
stay at a hundred the whole time it
would not go down the only thing that
would go down is the wattage and the CPU
frequency so you guys might be let's see
we're actually running at 15 and a half
watts right now and we typically would
be at around 13 or 12 in frequency it's
running at 2.2 gigahertz where before at
this point it would be running at about
1.7 gigahertz now look at the
temperature right there guys 55 54 53 it
looks like so the powers the wattage is
still going down we're at 12 watts now
kind of like before it held the boost
longer but that couldn't be just power
savings measures because our fan is
running at zero rpm it's shut off our
temperature is basically a idle now this
is kind of what it runs at idle 50
degrees where before I'd be running at a
hundred and we're running at 1.8
gigahertz right now where previously
we'd be running at 1.5 that's kind of
where it would stay up but at a hundred
degrees with the fans just going crazy
now I wonder why it's not keeping the
boost higher it has so much thermal
Headroom to be running much faster it's
just deciding not to let me do this let
me plug in the power and don't do this
at home please let's see if it decides
decides to kick up its wattage okay we
say you a little spike just to thirteen
point two six spiked a little bit so
yeah if you have power I mean typically
won't matter cuz it's gonna be running
at a hundred B Celsius but this time
around it jumped up to 1.9 gigahertz
and back down one point eight okay so it
doesn't care so basically this is just a
design of the MacBook Air and if the
MacBook Air had proper cooling it would
be running at 1.8 gigahertz after your
initial nice boost whereas now it's
running at 1.8 but completely silent and
a 5th degree Celsius instead
and here's our score 1137 so about 20%
faster than before keep in mind not only
is it 20% faster it's running at 50
degrees celcius compared to you a
hundred and in reality it actually could
run out about 2.3 or 2.5 gigahertz
instead of 1.8 I think Apple just knew
the things gonna get too hot and they
put in that hard limit because we're
only hitting 50 degree Celsius has a lot
more room there to turbo boost and run
faster but at least we know that if
Apple put in one slam heat pipe we could
get 20% better performance and much
cooler temperatures which is good for
long-term reliability and quiet fans but
they did not okay so now let's go ahead
and run a gaming test this is Unigine
heaven using the extreme preset and in
our last test it was really kind of
underwhelming even though the graphics
card wasn't too hot the CPU was running
at a hundred resources and of course
they're all in one chip so I'm guessing
how to kind of slow down so it's gonna
be interesting to see how much faster
the graphics could run if the CPU isn't
hitting 100 Celsius and so far been
running for about a minute and our
graphics is at 33 degrees Celsius and
our CPU is at 44 degrees Celsius that is
absolutely crazy okay in for some dumb
reason we look our graphics card usage
is only at 71 percent 73 percent it's
not being maxed out like it is with
other Macs and other Windows systems so
maybe there's another hard limit as far
as the the CPU speed the frequency what
it can run at because it's not being
maxed out and our memories not maxed out
either all right there we have it ten
point three FPS so that's about a 15
percent improvement and once again the
graphics card never run about above 75%
I have no idea why it doesn't make sense
CPUs at 43 degrees Celsius graphics is
at 32 I didn't think it's just touching
a heat sink to the bottom of the block
or just catching those two would make
such a big difference but I mean it did
so okay well this has been a
crazy experiment now let's get rid of
this let's put the back cover on and try
a much more reasonable solution
I set the laptop right on top of that
gel pack keep in mind I'm not telling
you guys to do this I really don't know
if there's issues with condensation or
anything like that but we'll see what
score we get here in Geekbench 5 we're
almost done here and okay 35 34 so
single core still about the same for
single core test this thing is so fast
multi-core we went from about 3200 to
3900 and now looks like we split
somewhere right in the middle so yes
putting your laptop on something cold
does help out it does kit help to keep
it cooler but not as good as actually
taking it and water cooling it and let's
finish up with a quick test of Cinebench
our 20 here okay 3.2 5 gigahertz right
now look at that spike and as soon as we
start doing some actual work 3 gigahertz
the CPU is capable of you know staying
there but we are getting some slowdowns
temps are staying decent now the whole
chassis is actually cold from sitting on
this pad for maybe 5 minutes or so
82 degrees 83 84 still at 2.1 gigahertz
all the cores and now we're heating up
92 degrees 93 94 91 a little bit it's
going back down that's because our CPUs
probably gonna be slowing down here so
we didn't hit a hundred we almost hit a
hundred now it's down to 91 90 so we
went down to that 1.8 that we saw with
actual liquid cooling we're going down
to 1.7 and I presume even lower and we
are almost done here and basically the
laptop settled at that same 1.8
gigahertz as we had when it was
water-cooled but the temps are higher
right now 95 but between 90 to 95
degrees and the laptop is running
completely silent as well so it looks
like we got about a 10% higher score
using this cooling gel packed with the
laptop instead of 20% higher when we
actually had the water cooling block
hooked up and then we had about 5 to 10
Celsius cooler temperatures but on top
of that the laptop ran
completely silent with this now I
probably still wouldn't suggest this may
be because of condensation but it
definitely makes a difference in what I
learned through all that through all of
this is that one the laptop wouldn't
have gotten that much faster but it
definitely would have given you 15 to
25% better performance lower
temperatures which is a big deal
especially for long-term and then also
quieter fan speeds as well so you guys
let me know your thoughts down in the
comment section below is this a cool
video for you guys to see did you get
any good insight from it and click that
little circle above if you guys want to
see our full review of the macbook air
if you want to see this compared to the
macbook pro in a ton of different tests
we have some great videos for you guys
right over there this max and i will see
you in the next video
[Music]